yeah look i want to ask you a couple
questions uh first of all when you were
doing psych
one the first movie right and that was
how many years ago maybe five four
right and you're like something like
that well you're about to film you're in
pre-production tell me if i'm wrong
and then one of your most beloved cast
members one of your best friends
tim amundson has a stroke out of the
blue i mean
talk about something that just i mean
how did obvio have you guys talked about
that i mean maybe i'm
i'm sure you have but like what was your
first response both of you like
and how did you react to it uh i mean i
was i was it was
shock i mean it's like the rug being
pulled out from underneath you
i believe that you hit me wrote i think
you called me yeah and i said i said
what like what
like it just even as i think about it
now
connecting those dots just didn't still
don't connect in my mind
wait what happened and it was really it
was to the level of being so serious
that we weren't even too sure if he was
going to make it
and again it's those type of moments of
life where life kind of goes
is put on his on his toes on his axis
goes on inside
where we're a few weeks away from going
to shoot a psych movie and then
now we're talking about whether now our
brother's actually even going to
see tomorrow i mean it just puts
everything
in perspective everything in perspective
but uh
you know thankfully we are such a family
where
as he did start to come through folks
really rolled up their sleeve and said
we're going to make this happen we're
going to make it happen
with him and for him and then it
keep you know keep on cheering him on
to then be able to get to the second
psych movie but i mean i
remember the moment he just really i was
i was shook and that's i
you know he still is a fake guy tim is
you know he's someone who exercised and
ride ride his bike all over the place
and this and that
i never would have expected that that
call
you know james
yeah uh it was devastating and a classic
example of
uh the perspective you gain when it
lands on your
on your own doorstep uh because you hear
stories
about stuff happening to young healthy
fit people
and uh until until it's right in front
of your face
it's it's surreal but it doesn't hit
home the same way
i mean like he was 47 years old he was
in the best shape of his life
and trust us we we knew him since he was
you know 30
something we saw all the different
versions of tim and and
he really truly was in the best shape of
his
no heart problems no pre-existing he uh
his career was apexing you know he was
coming up gallivant where he was sort of
the breakout
character of that show he had just
gotten another job where he was gonna be
working with carol burnett like
it was happening uh for him in a very
exciting way
and so the last thing the last phone
call you ever
ever expect to get is that someone in
that position
you know drops a major stroke
out of nowhere and someone called you
james someone to call you
yeah yeah i i heard from
from maggie uh who i heard i believe
from tim's wife
and uh yeah the record just
scratches and you stop and you don't
know what to say you don't know what to
do for a second
and uh and then you know because we're
all so close and we
you know we're all such a family we were
able to sort of shift gears
pretty quickly into what does tim need
what's the best thing to do
how can we help the family like it it
was a
it was a clear and obvious shift from
like
uh to action and
uh i mean i would expect nothing less
from this group but it really did
like that's what you do in that
situation when did when did
was the first time you guys talked to
him after it happened
it was a minute because like dooley said
there was like a week there where uh
his life was essentially hanging in the
balance and we were getting updates
but you know he wasn't really talking to
anybody
so uh i would say weeks
yeah weeks at least because i saw like a
little blurry now but i feel like i went
to see him
in at the rehab center
and that was the first time i actually
spoke to him how was that delay i mean
were you did you get him you had to get
emotional
of course yeah i mean uh i was emotional
as emotional on two sides it was
emotional because like it was uh
heartbreaking but it also was inspiring
because tim's spirit was
so big you know still trying to like
cracking jokes in the midst of
what he's going through and we just
like seeing i guess the the mental
fortitude that
he saw him forming in his mind to be
able to keep pressing forward was uh
was inspiring he keeps beating every
prognosis and
i'm sure he would be delighted to come
on and talk to you rosie because it's an
amazing story
and he you know he can tell a whole lot
better than we can but
you know it went from a priest coming to
read him his last rights in front of his
wife too doctors to doctors telling
you know allison just prepare yourself
there's a very good chance
that your husband's never going to walk
again and it's just like he just kept
clearing
hurdles you know um the dude's walking
around
uh you know it's he's he is an
inspiration
to to us all and he's also been
he's been very he's out there sort of as
a
uh stroke victim spreading you know the
word of like hey it doesn't have to
it doesn't have to end that's why i
brought it up because i feel like you
know he wants to get the message out
and i wanted to bring that up and i i
would love to talk to him i think
you